[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to the lobby
GameSpot's weekly video game hangout
here in San Francisco California I'm
your host Mike McCarty here where the
Jon loop Sykes John Luke site key not
Peter Brown how's it going pizza TGS
we're gonna get into some news from
there but we figured we'd bring you on
Rob Henry hey what's up and Kelly plague
hello who's almost done with destiny to
stuff covered finally yeah I just put up
a PvP beginners guide umm and I'm still
playing it but I think we're winding
down I'm playing danganronpa 3 now what
the hell is that now I'm just kidding
you know we can talk about that mortar
can you talk about it yet or is there
some reviews up yeah okay talk a little
bit about that
Jenna Lucian to turn off the audio on
our in-studio monitor so we don't have
an echo here ourselves we have a kind of
full show today like I said pizza tgs so
we've got some news out of there new
game from that Yoji Shinkawa working on
the artists of Metal Gear Fame new ship
new trailers and a new VR game
announcement which I'm sure everybody is
really excited for mods were gonna world
release date and then main parts of show
a little bit of pokken tournament DX is
finally on the switch we got echo indie
game that Rob and Pete have been raving
about and I got the chance to play a
little bit today finally people from IO
Interactive of hitman fame started on it
dishonored us the outsider which I am
loving so far and divinity original sin
2 which didn't really catch us off-guard
because the first one was really good
but this one kind of like just is
massive and really fun and it kind of
caught us off guard how much I'm loving
it at least but it caught me off guard
in that I forgot like when a that's out
next week alright
it's like him has been in like early
access and early codes yeah like full
disclosure as much like I just want to
say kevin van Ord former reviews editor
from GameSpot worked on a lot of the
writing for this game but of course it's
just a fantastic game in its own right
I saw I think game informer Dan tak over
at game for runners review called it's
the true successor to Baldur's Gate 2
like the classic isometric PC RPG that's
tough because they're arguably been
several Trinette successors to baldur's
gate to like high praise though ya know
definitely absolutely cool and then we
also have a giveaway which I'll get to
that at the end of the
show but as always I'm in the YouTube
chat twitch chat and we welcome your
comments concerns criticisms but mainly
the former increase and praise and
really nice compliments would be nice
too cool so TGS is happening or is
almost over kind of over in Tokyo yeah I
think it ends the 24th Peter Brown so
that's Sunday Peter Brown and Ed Tran
our UK editor or they're covering a AU
editor Thank You Australia are covering
it
Jake Decker is also in Australia they
kind of swapped so Jake will be our ad
and that will be our P and then Pete can
be John Luke
but yeah so Metal Gear artists would
like an OG Shinkawa what do you get to
be yeah you could be Mike
Yoji Shinkawa is working on a mech game
called left alive
they showed it a little bit and it's
coming from Square Enix no release date
yet but they showed kind of a teaser
trailer during the show
it's like shining a hallway I got
excited when I first when I open up
GameSpot the next morning cuz a lot of
this happened like our time at night I
looked at GameSpot I saw Yoji Shinkawa
and I saw his you know like iconic metal
garish art I was like wait what is he
doing I mean this could be fun I'm
obviously it's a teaser trailer but it's
always just nice what is it about
like what do you don't know much I just
know it's called left alive and it's a
mech game this city got pretty [ __ ] up
Mac's are cool mechs are super cool yeah
titanfall to anyone else get like a
deaths cannon vibe to me I'm like that
hallway shot yeah yeah cinematic like
what they're trying to like the emotion
they're trying to evoke in the trailer
yeah it doesn't really go quite that far
but I don't know yeah it's like it I get
a lot of like mecha anime vibes from the
setting like I feel like the apocalyptic
Tokyo esque thing is pretty popular so
see iconic mecha anime would it be gonna
Gundam if I Gillian has Mexican long and
her logins has Mexican login has no
America she named her dog after a
character from that yes no no he's the
main character who drives her she never
dogs Simone because the character is C
Mon the digger he digs and
dogs out Josh Shaw's on our twitch chat
right now former GameSpot employee says
I have a question for Rob Rob where's
the last Jedi trailer you promised me
why'd you promise them with why are you
in charge that what yeah that's what you
said I saw this on Twitter was it today
they remember when Rob tweeted about it
and then Disney told him to take that
tweet down yeah for those who don't know
it was Monday Night Football this yeah
Josh AWS yeah it was Monday a screenshot
of a Mark Hamill tweet teasing something
for September 19th no it was October no
it's October just kidding anyway it was
October okay Jesus
anyways marcantel yeah he tweeted
something and then deleted it and then
his response was like it was a joke I
was it was like an inside joke on like
the two teams were playing was it the
Bears and Vikings are some like that 84
gesture acts in the YouTube chat saying
next week Monday Night Football next
week is the 29th no so wow I'm Way off
25th is Monday and then week after that
seven days from then there was another
in that day it's dude okay Disney is
really good luring all the lines and
like just like I think they even have a
team no they seriously have a team that
is devoted to like trolling the internet
and like screwing with like rumors and
stuff like what did you Josh Shaw and
the twitch team for derailing your
conversation I didn't really do much to
stop it there's a new trailer for Shadow
of the Colossus the ps4 remake which I'm
pretty pumped for has everybody here
have you had no no you were saying
you're pretty pumped this could you've
not played it nice I've also not played
it sorry it's uh I'm not I'm not kids
over here that yeah I'm sorry I'm not
like you know alone in it but it's one
of my favorite games hmm
ball though going back on ps3 the
controls are one thing that I had you're
constantly battling I would say like
it's supposed to be kind of tenuous when
you're climbing on it the I'm all set
Titans on the colossi but it just it's
kind of it feels janky so I'm hoping
with ps4 kind of a lot of the ps4
remakes or Canole Resident Evil's those
are different for the tank controls but
I'm hoping maybe they'll refine some of
the mechanics they just got a strict
that balance where they don't go too far
and it makes the game
less'n difficult yeah there's that
there's a really fine balance and I do
think they could update it they just
can't go too far with it well yeah
there's also like designed difficulty
versus difficulty by nature of like
janky nests so like it can still be
difficult without being frustrating and
unfair no totally yeah um but I I'm
really excited about like classic
favorite games getting remix cuz a lot
of those games came out at time where I
didn't have time to play a lot of games
and so I'm super pumped about it and I
know a lot of people like to revisit
these games but I think it's cool that
it's like oh here's an updated version
of something that maybe you didn't have
a chance to check out yeah
I'm looking forward to playing that
again for I don't know maybe the fifth
time we found a stream cuz I like I have
a favorite Colossus I would say it's the
the bird on the lake no pop and grab
just well I oh yeah that one's great too
love that one it's okay so SCI Games
announced zone of the enders Anubis Mars
which is a VR game for ps4 and PC and
it's a redone version of the zone of the
Ender's the second runner on ps3 so it's
like the second zone of the Ender's
erekt a was kind of wondering whether
that would make him nauseous because
zone of the Ender's as you could see if
you're watching this right now right
like a character ish actor as an action
game is kind of a frantic I'm already
feeling like I would get super sick
playing this probably it's so I've never
heard of zone evander so we're like
doing what is it oh yeah doom in VR is
the same thing I know Harrison Ford's in
it but kid controls things
yeah Kojima did he do the most of them
yeah zona Anders is probably most famous
for if you got it it came with the demo
for Metal Gear Solid 2 yeah so everyone
got it for that mm gotcha
they still did that these days imagine
if like well it was the last one cracked
battleborn came with a yeah crackdown 3
demo or no no you're talking about
crackdown less time no yeah the
crackdown came with the beta code for
Halo 3 I think that's the last example I
can think of
but there was something else with Halo
with the beta that wasn't there was
another one that was the halo 3 beta it
was for like four if you like that goes
you could play halo 4 beta I'm kidding I
feel like now yeah now it's just like
they give out codes or it's a pre-order
it's not right crusher redbull there's a
code at the bottom that gives you access
to I've done this in III but so that's
why a lot of people have heard of it
then is that what you're saying I'm
saying that's like problem that was
probably people's like a lot of people
seeked it out because of metal gear but
it definitely has its like hardcore fans
that love that game Monster Hunter world
release date it's announced January 26
of the next year 2018 on ps4 Xbox one
and then the PC version will follow at a
later date which as of yesterday when I
was writing this they have not announced
I might I've been maybe it's because
2017 has been conditioning me to try so
many new kinds of games but I kind of
want to try this because I don't really
traditionally playing Monster Hunter
games I played Monster Hunter 3 for like
5 hours which of course is nothing
that's like playing dota 2 for 20 hours
yeah I want to try this just because I
know how hardcore Monster Hunter fans
are and I would love to start getting
why they love these games so much and
maybe this would be a good opportunity
because January like Tay was saying it's
kind of dead right now in terms of
releases you got Far Cry 5 in February
but today was comparing it to that neo
release date earlier this year where
they had kind of that weird window to
kind of you know be the only game
releasing as of now so I don't know do
we have any do you play Monster Hunters
gently could feel like no but my friend
has been trying to get me to play it for
years I think Jake is the only person
the office he really plays more earlier
but the reason part of well part of its
the commitment but the other part was
when he was to get me to play him there
was the 3d s1 was and I was like I don't
really wanna like oh that's just not
really what I'm interested in playing
that game kind of game on a 3ds but
having it on like the PC or you know a
PlayStation 4 definitely seems more
appealing that thing I saw people on
Twitter calling that the traveler yeah
this is actually I think kind of the
game that I would rather play on through
yes
but really yeah but also I'm weird and I
just like handhelds but I am excited I
mean it looks gorgeous and the monsters
like the monster design is always
fantastic and yeah this is another game
that I think like I should like I think
I would like it I just haven't tried it
because it is kind of an intimidating
idea but there's cats in it so there's
like the the destiny idea right this
like daily grind that you get into and
like yeah call start calling it chores I
feel like I only have time in my life
for Animal Crossing in one other game
like that stardew valley uh no start
eval you don't have to do everyday but I
like Animal Crossing is a game that I
will regardless of what I'm doing I'll
play every day right but like if I'm
right now I'm doing destiny and so I
just don't know how many games I can
like that I can fit right into my
schedule I definitely want to try it
I've played a very little Monster Hunter
and it always feels good to play and the
like I said the monster design is super
cool so you're into monsters and I liked
some of the footage I saw of like just
like the ecosystem of like you know
there's always a bigger fish type of
thing where it's like you just to kind
of explore and watch like these giant
like there's one it was like just like a
guano looking thing and just swallowed
another monster whole pageant gotta play
it at PAX and I was like watching him
play a little bit and he's like I
remember what they were fighting me he's
just raining it looks like a massive
like dinosaur type creature and as
they're fighting it like on another one
just shows up and he's just watching
them fight each other as he's just kind
of sitting there underneath he's like
just like oh ok well I guess um try and
hit it and then one of them like hits is
like hits him with the tail and goes
flying off this waterfall I'm all the
way back up stuff like badge it seems
like really cool yeah just watching like
these massive creatures like fight each
other and you're just kind of a little
little dude in the middle of it all yeah
like if you ever like I don't know if
you guys are the type of weird that I am
where I'll like look at charts of like
ancient animals compared to like the
size of a person let me like giant sloth
and it'll have a like a tiny person next
to it like that's crazy it's so big the
Megalodon
thinking out loud but I'm getting from
that idea of just like this is I am
nothing in this world but I still have
the power to fight these and hunt these
giant monsters yeah they took you for a
star to valley casual Kellie we do have
one giveaway today then we will get you
at the end of the show wait I don't like
that game okay pokken tournament DX
I didn't play pokken on Wii U I like
Pokemon and I like fighting games a lot
more in recent years so this seemed like
a good time to try it out and I tried it
out new features new characters the CID
UI you can use what's that
it's the owl but it's the turtle has a
cannons on its shoulders oh yeah
I'm kidding sorry I'm done oh you what
is he he's an owl that has a bow and
arrow okay from Sun and Moon yeah he's
cool any fun claim by each other looks
so sad so it was actually cool at PAX we
got to I think this might be the foot it
is yeah we had to pro players check out
the new characters so they added said UI
they added what there's I think in cinah
roar they added like I think four new
ones to pokken tournament DX and it was
cool because like one of the things
that's interesting about pokken and this
is what Matt Padgett kept bringing up
he's he was really annoyed that it's not
more fighting-type pokémon he's like why
is it hitmonchan in this game I'm tops
and like Hirata who was involved in the
production was saying that like that
would be too obvious so that would be
cool to showcase what other Pokemon can
do without falling into that like it's a
fighting-type it knows fighting-type
moves so a lot of interesting things and
there's like some characters that have
weird like void attacks and they've
interesting supers and so it sort of
mixes like it's a 3d fighting game it's
a you know it's Pokemon and Tekken but
it kind of has a unique flavor to it
then it has things like anime style
supers that are really cool to watch if
you play like a Dragon Ball fighting
game or a Naruto fighting game
they kind of do like zoom out like
cinematic like the Pokemon does this
cool crash into the ground stuff boom
yeah you can see here on the right side
if you're watching it they added Papa
Leo and Litton as support characters so
that's kind of an ability that's one
kind of something you've built up
throughout the match and then use it
some have different attacks some have
these long-range attacks and then arcade
characters tell me if I'm pronouncing
enemies wrong cheese or scizor scizor I
doesn't he say she's or he might but
that's because Japanese doesn't have a
system okay Scizor yeah mmm Darkrai mmm
po Leon and Croagunk yep cool they are
also there in the arcade all Manny's I
want to give my channel yes so I was
wrong about in the center or they had
the Litton that was daily challenge
fights if you wanna keep playing it
Croagunk go back to the third evolution
of Croagunk is a it's actually
uninvolved pokemon and it's poison
fighting type x and y know I think it's
from Diamond I I can't quite remember
third or fourth he's our third yeah I
sometimes get those middle generations
mixed up but he's a poison fighting type
and I love poison types and there's like
no poison types that you can use and he
falls into Toxicroak but they went with
Croagunk which i thought was interesting
because it's a lot cuter than toxic rook
yeah and I was telling uh who was it
oh we were doing like a reboot episode
yesterday Jake and I and I was saying
when that first
reveal traveller for the switch came out
and that showed people like crowding
around just the screen playing with the
joy Kahn's like that's never gonna
happen that's [ __ ] I did it with
this game the other day playing some of
the office and actually it's not the
ideal way to play but I was like I kind
of see how the appeal to this uh you
know there's like no TV around it's cool
we're in the park trying to enjoy nature
and then uh no it's [ __ ] I was pokin
totally one of those kids that brought
the Gameboy to the park so I feel that
right so you can say you went outside
then you get vitamin D either way that
was a big thing for me in elementary
school like a playground
I brought Pokemon dose yeah yeah I think
kids are doing that with like switches
no they do cocaine now I would I would
rock the switch at recess every day
we had 2% do that I feel like a switch
is maybe a little more fragile than
original Gameboy I would not let my kid
I would bring I probably cracked like
now I would let my kid bring a 3ds maybe
because they are a little more sturdy
sure they probably definitely they
definitely bring and there's actually
you can recover your data on a 3ds I'm
like yeah but yeah like I like I I like
that idea of I mean you're enjoying
nature but the real thing is you get a
little sunlight you get some vitamin D
and you play some book in or playing or
like on a flight next to your friend
yeah or or even like if somebody else is
using the TV like that's just you I
right there in the left Rob my
girlfriend or at the IKEA we were
waiting for a lift home it was like 20
minutes so I just like pulled out my
switch is in my backpack
wait okay really quickly did you
furniture with you know put in the lift
or just wait for fun no he got the
switch at I can oh we got yeah we got
some Oh like smaller yeah we got like a
desk and stuff overcooked that was
actually like perfect so we just play
come around so that is that running
better I don't know when I got it when I
was playing it was not that was right
when it came out so it was not running
amazing but it was still running well
enough that we could play it and enjoy
it and I don't know if it's been fixed
though you and I arrived yesterday we're
talking about how some games feel better
handheld like the switch it's the ideal
ploy ideal way to play a lot of games
like I love playing Zelda handheld um
I'm kind of nervous about how I'm gonna
feel about handheld with doom and
Wolfenstein and shooters because the I
don't know the balance and the
controller isn't there it's such a wide
it's not as bad as the Wii U or anything
but it's such a wide kind of a center of
gravity for your hands if that makes any
sense yeah um so that's one thing I'll
say about poking DX
it doesn't really play that well
handheld okay because it's such a like
it's a fighting game so you're worried
about your combos and and it's not like
it's not you're not like rotating your
sticks for moves it's very much like
this direction or that direction plus a
button it's like you know like it like
tekken is the obvious it's not this
example but it's like a more much more
complicated smash bros i guess if you
play that a lot you know what that
precision and like this
yeah you don't have to be worrying about
holding the entire switch I guess but
with like a pro controller or the
regular like it's fine yeah like you
think I I think about like with breath
of the wild like handheld the biggest
frustration I mean the motions there's
one part that came to I'm like God but
like the the aiming down with a boat
like aiming and like finding that
handheld yeah I would have liked like I
feel like I would always be off or like
I don't know I did yeah precision I feel
like what the program Tyler is just like
so much more better but like yeah but
that you mean whenever I'm fine
firing a bow in Zelda I'm not
necessarily moving all the time you
think about something like doom which is
like my fear or like any kind of like
first-person shooters like how is that
going to be when you're also moving in
lining up [ __ ] like it's a it's a ballet
that's what doom is right like yeah it
depends I think splatoon plays way
better with motion right because that
game you're constantly moving and then
also managing your aim and so it I think
it does work pretty seamlessly I don't
know how a port will do that though you
have to very like I mean a game that
wasn't made for that how do you adapt
that right I would just rather play that
not emotionally yeah like when you're
incorporating like headshots a super
ultra precise stuff yes like a fear I
have put well see ya pokken tournament
DX is out now as of last no no sorry
this Friday September 22nd on Nintendo
switch so if you pick that up if you
wanna anybody are you guys planning on
it I know you did you plan on with you
much no not really I'm not a huge
fighting game person I just played like
six rounds of Blaziken yesterday
Blaziken rules okay yeah but then it
took me I was playing X&Y and I loved
X&Y it took me maybe two weeks before I
realized that he was a chicken like and
then the name made sense and then a
stupid well no that happens to me too
like it took me a really long time I'm
probably like the ones where I was
younger right be like Oh squirt turtle
mm-hmm
squirrel it was way less sexual when I
thought yeah I didn't that was a bad
example because of the Ekans
it's a snake backwards oh yeah
what's the klefki is that just a set of
keys yeah where's the clef coming from I
don't know just very handsome he's got
that chin kleptomaniac keys yeah it's
pokken tournament DX if you didn't play
on the way you I would encourage you to
pick it up on the switch I like it a lot
been reading other places people are
feeling the same again I didn't really I
wasn't super indigent endo during the
WiiU years aside from a few fantastic
games but now that the switch is kind of
like my favorite console I was nice to
get into that so this game echo Rob
former IO Interactive employees of who
made hitman when how many years ago -
three two years what last hitman hitman
I came out last year that was last year
yeah damn okay cool Oakland bro your
game of the year yeah that was two years
ago but anyway former IO Interactive
employees from it's the studio ultra
ultra it's the first game Copenhagen
their first game as an indie studio they
made Eko
and it's not getting according to Rob as
much press as it deserves and Robin
playing it a lot and he's been trying to
get me to play and I want it to but but
a trying week but I'm really trying to
get a lot if not everyone in the world
to play this game so I just want to hear
more about it because I have my own you
know my own opinion but I want to I kind
of scoured reddit this make yeah this
just came out yesterday I looked on
ready I looked around I'm seeing some
talk about it and if you see right now
ps4 not yet oh it's not out on ps4 yet
now I thought there is it coming to ps4
Robin I definitely want to play it but
like you came up to me and you were like
do you want to code and I was like
absolutely but I have no time for this
game it's it's been a hell of a year so
it's like understandable but I don't
know like I just I would expect more
people to know about this game because I
it's anyways it for those of you do not
know what EKKO is all right so clarify
really quick that's a dear Elliott says
that it should be out on ps4 but I
searched it today did not I was under
yeah I thought it was maybe like
obviously like in the search so many
things showed up with echo but there was
no echo game anyway yes what is it so
what is this game it's a it's a
third-person stealth game it's got a lot
of sci-fi horror but not nothing that's
I would I would say should steer anyone
who was say like you know afraid of like
that that genre shoot super heavy sci-fi
though the premise is that you are this
character named n who was also the
character from Game of Thrones voiced by
what's-her-name in Cary Ygritte the
redhead Jordan Snow that's yes yes so
explain it so you you you reside in this
place called the palace and it's just
it's a stealth game at heart where you
have objectives like if we get from A to
B among other things but what you're
dealing with is the enemy and the
tagline for this game is like the enemy
is you in that the game goes through
cycles so you have your light cycle and
your dark cycle a light cycle you move
around and anything you do in that dirt
during that cycle say vaulting over a
table sprinting shooting anything the
game remembers it it hits a black site a
blackout period I'll talk about that
later and then when the next light cycle
starts everything you did in the
previous one is incorporated into these
characters called echoes which are
basically replicants of yourself and
there are a whole bunch of them and they
will do basically what you were doing
the previous cycle so you really are
like playing against yourself so the
more I play this game the more I love
because the the game also has pretty
great map design and end up with that a
puzzle element of like you're limited to
different things so say I'll give you
the counter that I think was my
favorites when I enter in a room and in
this room are two cages filled with
echoes they're just looking at me
they're unable to escape there are doors
but they're unable to walk out I'm like
okay fine so I keep walking down and
they're following with me within this
hallway the 2k
on both left and right side and I notice
that the light cycles about to end but
what I had just done is open a door you
begin to realize oh my god when the next
cycle starts all of these goes no how
know how to open doors and they're gonna
chase you and and kill you immediately
so it's time time time time again you
find yourself in these puzzles that seem
to be easy on face value but then
they're just like they're extremely
difficult I was on one last night that
took me like about an hour to get
through and it was fun so cool it is so
cool it makes my I reserved in the light
cycle because I exactly tube chat was
just saying so what if you didn't shoot
or run ostensibly they wouldn't be able
to shoot or sprint the next round it's
good question so this is what I
eventually began to realize that the
light cycles are not determined that the
lengths are not determined on time but
information so how much information they
gather from you from you so if I'm
crouching it'll only remember a few
instances so they kind of amount so like
if I went crazy and I spun around
shooting vaulting eating grapes playing
the piano you could see yeah you so you
can create distractions so there's
there's yeah so you can play a piano
you're kidding no you can play the piano
and the next time it's so eerie that
echoes are like you just hear in the
distance they're playing the piano
because that's what you were doing it is
really cool as far as like the horror
elements of like what they do like they
like for instance if I cross water is
one of them so like I'll enter a room
and there's there's like a moat a moat
around them and they're just looking at
the water and they're looking at you and
they see you because they detect you and
they just are like waiting yeah and so
the end so with the this was a really
crazy they're really creepy so another
interesting part is during the black the
blackout cycle during the blackout cycle
anything goes the palace is not
remembering so that's where you can make
dashes and moves like shoot it's really
where I'm find myself shooting the most
as during these right like literally
black out
it's literally black out you'll see it
in a little bit like right oh I was
about to happen there
ah a gnat right there on the left was
the only time so the save points are
really Shu and far between which is fine
because it really no generates that
sense of like you know fear of basically
restarting I'm that you could argue both
ways against that but I like it I like
having that that that weight of like oh
my god
this is like my last-ditch effort I'm
outta ammo so yeah so again so anything
goes during the blackout period so
that's where you're making moves or like
desperate kind of risk reward factors so
right here the thing though about the
blackouts is that like oh man it's
really hard to see so like you'll find
time and time again yourself forgetting
what you did in the previous light cycle
so there was one time I was like I was
just sprinting like a madman so during
the blackout it still carries over so I
was just like oh yeah this echo behind
me she's like you know really far away
no problem and I turn around and this is
Jay she's a whole on Sprint about to
grab me so the other part too is that
your health is really low and your
stamina is really low as well so they
grab you once you'll see it there's like
a button mash prompt to push them away
and then your HUD basically turns red
right there a little bit if they touch
you again you're dead
dang yes it's like straight up it's
almost like survival stealth totally
there's a lot of very very harsh there
are some horror elements too especially
in the intro Robin you were kind of
watching me please yeah slow burn but
Ben Janka here on a GameSpot team was
saying he was surprised of how they
played up the horror aspect and I agree
because I was watching you play I was
like that's kind of creepy and really
like the uncanny nosov attacking he was
weird but they definitely play that up
at the beginning at least and I would
imagine it yeah watching gameplay and
just inherently kind of follows through
the rest of the game for sure and again
it's just and so we we had a reviewer
who reviewed it to be honest I was just
in Clark yes that's right he brought up
a good point as far as like you know any
kind of gripes would there be with this
game
I personally I've been okay with it I
have not finished it but this was all my
fears coming in was that you are from
the most part in this this palace and it
does look the same for the most part
throughout your plays but I think he
beat it in seven hours what I would say
though he said the palace is changing
like
yeah you're getting the same
architecture but I would say like that
like without spoiling like there is
there's a character within the palace
that's really fascinating as you
progress pretty much in the same light
of like these characters learning so
here it is so if I get touched again I'm
done and that's what happens yeah if
there's oh the other thing too so how
many of these echoes is is the the
frightening part so you go you go into
room and you just see about 12 them
you're like oh my god this sucks cuz
then all it takes is three of them to be
near you if you're a full health to take
you down like to you can manage but
anymore is like difficult yeah I don't
know I can't speak it's got me hooked
and just for though it for anyone just
joining we're talking about we're
talking about echo from IO or sorry
former IO Interactive developers of a
hitman to clarify Felipe I'd are in the
twitch chat was asking if IO Interactive
still exists yeah they do there they
regain the rights to hitman in 2017 from
Square Enix after they bought it from I
das interactive but now IO interactive
is independent and doing hitman stuff
presumably in the future but a few
people broke off in also in Copenhagen
to do echo so you can kind of get a
sense of their their portfolio and what
their you know their pedigree is I have
a question for you Mike there is I feel
like when the things also when we saw
the the preview they came the office
they just saw just like one little level
and the palace with no voiceover or
story really in it yet he he was admin
saying though there is a story like do
you think so far it's been an engaging
an understandable story for you like
yeah the one the one gripe all have is
the beginning is kind of more of a slow
burn than I would like
yeah I I mean I don't know it's such a
unfair game to compare it to but like
breath of wild years and immediately
into it so many games I play this year
I'm immediately into it but it makes
sense within the world cuz they're kind
of showing you in the gameplay that your
actions are going to have consequences
and the story I'm hearing through this
AI character of London
I say yeah his voice actor sounds like
Sean Bean like weirdly was not he was um
he was he does a lot of work I forgotten
his name but he was in hell blade right
he did hell blade and he's done he's got
like a pretty good list on I'm do you
have video games but yet answer a
question
I think it's doing that Gears of War
thing or anytime he's talking to you it
slows you down to a trot yeah my horse
but yeah they will I think yeah you're
right I was frustrated that as well
because it is a slow burn until you get
into the palace where like all the
footage you really just saw is like you
know that's the meat of the game that's
where you want to get to in terms of
setting up the vibe and the the
atmosphere it's a very good intro yeah
yeah I found that I've been a lot less
patient with longer intros lately um
probably because I have so many games to
get to but like you think about like
something like The Witcher 3 or it's
like sometimes like that game took me a
long time to get going or like even
Duncan rumpa 3 like the first chapter is
like 6 hours and there's reasons for
that but it's like part of me is just
kind of too impatient lately and I I
don't know like I'm just waiting for the
hook right I don't know if that's just
like I got like I'm old and jaded and
tired of stuff or anything I I will say
like the slow burn is there's a payoff
and I think Ben speaking I got man just
been trying to get people to play this
so I can talk about it but if I was able
to talk about one thing I thought was
somewhat spoilery but so freaking cool I
won't spoil it but like the setup to
like where like it's a really cool 7 it
builds and you know you just start
seeing like oh my god it's this is this
is ramping up really nicely I can't
speak without spoiling it so I won't
here here's a wrench in the cogs what if
you just like you go into the light
section the first one when they're kind
of learning from you and you just love
them next turn they're just gonna come
up and just hey man I was also thinking
can you like a makeout with them and
then teach them to make people in both
you do then twist your hats when they
grab you it looks like you guys are
trying so hard to make out with you yeah
but they're not human they just want to
like crush your face it's the palace
like manifests right trying to kill you
or I would see em just saying it took
him around an hour to get to the first
like light puzzle room it's there's a
reward factor to like the Reimann reason
for these things it's like the more I
play this game I keep continually having
these like
Oh or like oh my god moments where I
like another I get set up was like this
huge like in the palace just like we
call like a light well or like a like a
terrorist's I don't know with the series
but the only way to get down just by
vaulting over railings mm-hmm but you
look and you look down and you see all
these like maybe like a dozen floors and
there's just all these echoes I'm just
looking at you but then you start
realizing oh once I started faulting
once the next light cycle happens
they're gonna be vaulting down and sure
enough that happens to sorts like you're
just rushing to get down because you
know and as the audio ramps up and
builds and swells that something's gonna
happen and you need to be long gone out
of there
I'm just imagining what if that happened
in real life and you had replicants of
yourself chasing you and so like when
the light was on you had to hand them
like Nintendo switches and then the next
round you just get a [ __ ] ton of them
okay dinner money oh just hand them a
twenty and they all have to give you a
twenty after that like I would go into
an investment you know I do I would like
go into your house and like break a
couple of dishes and then like lock the
door and leave and then all of your
replicants wake up there's just sixteen
Rob handler he's routing through my
cupboards get out of my house Rob Rob
did it again we need to stop doing this
Rob yeah or Charlie you clean your
dishes there just do all then you go
home and you're like ah my house is
spotless now there's not like mr.
meeseeks or some comedic potential
they'd go that route they went yeah Eko
it is out it's definitely out on PC
apparently it's out on ps4 now according
to every page I just looked at it's like
I said former IO Interactive hit man
makers IO Interactive still does exist
and has the rights to hitman as an
independent studio but go check that out
it's $25 although it was down to 21
today sort of sale so worth it yeah Pete
and Rob been talking about it a lot and
I definitely wanna play more there's a
slow burn at the beginning but push past
it cuz everything I've seen Rob play
looks really fun like I'm and I'm
already thinking like one I would I
would like to see this game
streamed but too there is a difficulty
ramped up like I would I'm playing like
damn I actually kind of want to see what
this is like on it's like hardest so I
think there is a replayability
back to there that is worth checking out
yeah I'm sold John Luke you beat
dishonored death the outsider he's
standalone DLC from Arkane studios
they're their European office over in Y
my blanket honest I did a whole memory
series Thank You Leon they released this
famil in DLC the last Friday yep and you
beat it over the weekend played through
it there's what five discreet missions
there's five missions you depending good
Val long you take it if you like you can
pro like rush through it like kind of
mainline it and it'll take you maybe
like five six hours but there's also
like the big new thing and this one is
there like contracts and stuff you can
do which add these like extra little
like kind of bonus objectives that you
can do to earn extra cash which is very
thief like I wish dishonor to had that
system they were side quest and dishonor
to that you could do but I feel like
it's so it's structured much better in
this in a way I didn't find us on or -
it gets you to think about levels
differently where you're like I I was
like okay I would end up going inside
like buildings that like there was no
reason to go into before or they never
found myself going into and it's like oh
I need to go over there to find this
person and sometimes it's like kill it
do you bother times it's like you got to
make this mine look like he committed
suicide so you gotta like knock him out
and then you got in the process of
suicide you know like throw him off of
it no yeah it's a famous suicide site in
Carnival you're not done wall yeah yeah
just like but reading the just like
dishonour to and pray both from arcane
and everything they've done it does a
good job of contextualizing all the
quests so like you just said okay
without just straight-up telling you the
objectives although you have journal
entries but you'll be like oh I think I
might know how to do this and then there
you know alternate paths to get there
but um yeah you're playing is Billy lurk
right what's what's she all about yes so
Billy was a character from - Megan
Foster was like they're kind of a Lee
she was going under she like ran the
ship the dreadful whale which is the
which is like the hub area in two
and her whole back story is that she
used to be an assassin for doubt who is
the assassin who murdered the Empress in
the original game and you actually
played as him in a DLC which were very
good DLCs by the way if no one's ever
played the knife of dunwall DLC it's
like absolutely fantastic and this kind
of feels like it's more in a way almost
like a sequel to that game and well
where it's like continuing off of like
let's go that idea and so they do a lot
of interesting things by her being an
assassin so they like yeah you guys
because you get amber from in it because
I burned the dog for that contract yeah
but if blowflies if you kill what guys
for input flies in them you get but uh
no because she's an assassin they they
got rid of the karma system like that's
just not a thing in this game right
which is really really cool because that
was sort of always a big complaint I had
with dishonored was that the games very
much about experimentation but it
punishes you from a story perspective
before doing it and it's like an
interesting idea but you're like okay I
feel like I have to reload my save
because I messed up and I want to get
the good ending dishonor one wasn't just
it didn't just punish you in terms of
story like the more people you killed
the more like dangerous rats they're
worth - yeah that was punishment - yeah
that was cool I actually like that part
like that was Annie because it's like oh
you're killing more people which spreads
the disease so there are more rats like
that that was neat but more like
specifically the story stuff like yeah
like I said it's got a hit-or-miss for
me I like how you can talk to rats now
yes that's a you know actually they're
really gross they're like like blood
sweet blood we want students not
surprising like all right makes a lot of
sense to get rid of the karma system and
I feel like I'm just I have more freedom
to experiment and I I didn't feel like I
had to I never felt that compulsion to
necessarily like reload my save where
it's like oh I got caught cuz instead it
was like I got caught but it's just this
one guy and if I'm quick enough I
kill him yeah alarm everyone and I was
able to do that and then keep going and
I felt like that was just it felt a lot
better to play that way like the game
still has when you beat the mission it
still has like the the checks like oh
did you do it all non-lethal so for
those who want that challenge they can
still absolutely do that but the game
doesn't feel like it's it's forcing you
to be as compulsive about that and the
other game it's rude I like a lot we're
going to do any favorite new abilities I
like for sight we talked about this yeah
so super good um seems kind of I think
it's gonna be hit or miss for some
people um
Alessandro in his review kind of talked
about how he was a little disappointed
that you get three new powers in the
game at the beginning but that's all you
get you don't get any new powers over
the rest of the clean Dishonored 2 works
like you've got a ton of powers but
you're but you're putting like
progression into the same not at all
there's no other progression
it's just bone charms that you can which
are the little extra upgrading gear and
upgrading gear he's good for your black
market you aren't upgrading there's no
skill tree for the powers this time and
I think some people are gonna find that
disappointing because they want to like
get those new powers but for me when I
think about the way I played just
honored 1 and 2 is I would typically
find those like several powers that I
found the most addictive and I would
just stick with them and I would never
use anything right and so this game I
kind of like that it just for it just
gives you three powers that are all very
useful and specific and I found myself
constantly using all three powers so
those two feeling like I just had these
extra powers that I didn't use so I kind
of that's probably more manageable right
and that game because then you're really
just thinking about okay how can I
maximize the use of this one power like
me where I would freak out about being
like I'm i choosing the right one or
shall I confess how do I want to kill
like there's so many options you know
Domino was in this game I don't have it
so that was me showing when you beat the
game you then can do a New Game+ with
Dishonored 2 powers and you get dark
vision but it's still only just the
three it's just kind of replaces the
three other ones which doesn't need
that's it that's a cool really yeah but
I like like dark vision like I know I'm
dark vision sucks now it's dark vision
from what and ii was like it's like the
batman vision it's in every game right
you can see it through walls and see
enemies and this you get for site where
you can
basically you like astral project
yourself out of your body as Callie very
much remembers from that one and you can
like mark targets and all this stuff and
it just gives you way more like tactical
freedom to like actually like experiment
and be like okay I can like tag that guy
can tag that guy and kind of look around
a corner and see what's going on and
like going back to like dark vision I
was like oh okay whatever I can see
through a wall like that's cool I guess
I was yeah I was gonna say it's like it
sounds far more manageable to like okay
I got three powers which I can like use
on the fly right yeah then you're also
focusing sounds like more on like actual
combat right yeah combat and gadgets get
these uh like hook mines that like pull
people towards them and you can actually
set them to be lethal or non-lethal
which is pretty cool it's um really mess
with people oh yeah well cuz it like
pulls them and you can like pull them
and then they're just like hanging from
like a wall or something you can also
use it to like there's a cheap minim
premium cut you're hit their head off I
did a lot of that there's an achievement
apparently I haven't tried it yet for
like you can use the hook mine to launch
someone like 50 feet in the air
hmm is it achievement for it that's
funny but yeah just like having these
powers and then using them in like more
creative ways like semblance where you
can steal someone's face and then like
walk past guards you say that's so
matter-of-factly weirdo fermenting with
that particular parents thing like okay
like what did the woman oh where can i
push this one power like how far can I
do that as a mean Hey between semblance
he took his face off I went to a wedding
recently where face off was playing on a
projector the entire reception I wonder
whose wedding that was yeah between
semblance in death the outsider and
being an undead character in divinity
original sin - I am ripping so many
faces this week it's kind of become my
MO and just will get to it divinity
original sin to the undead characters
scare people I feel you're about to say
RIP in so many farts just ripping ass
clouds also
minor trivia I think a lot of people
know this that are like play played
dishonored odd the dreadful well my name
the ship is an anagram for farewell
doubt yeah Harvey Smith told me that
yeah and I had no idea and that was
that's kind of cool and also doubt the
character you know who he's voiced by oh
I do but I forgot Michael Madsen and
Michael mr. blonde like right Tarantino
movies yeah he doesn't get much work
anymore it's really cool to see this
come out after things like The Lost
Legacy these standalone DLCs like double
a size right yeah for 30 bucks is
absolutely I think worth playing I mean
it's also got Larry all that replay
value I was like messing with the game's
custom difficulty which was a thing they
patched into too but they didn't patch
it into like several months after that
game came out so I never went back and
tried it yeah we showed a little bit of
that menu earlier you're gonna do a
feature later in the week on that yeah
it's when I have some more time but I
actually got to play and is it gets real
it's weird what are some of the things
you can change you can change so much so
you can change like how loud your
footsteps are you can change like enemy
perception so you can see it's like oh
they can now they're more aware of like
what's above them so like just being
above a dude it's not gonna necessarily
write these things like how much your
health regenerates how quickly
regenerates yeah that's also a
difference there are no more how like
how like far you can lean and then how
much enemies can see when you're leaning
like you can get really my own specific
are very very specific and then you can
also set like Ironman mode which is I so
you can set it to have a one safe slot
and then you can do an Ironman run which
is where it'll the quicksave does not
work it only saves it specific times and
then when you die you know just whites
are safe and I got I love 19 minutes in
it was I'm just saying I got further
than I thought I would and this was with
me I also turned everything on and so I
set everything to the hardest it could
possibly be and put on Ironman I feel
like if you man like she's got a cool I
feel like if you maxed everything out
you like would take one step and then
explode it's not that it's actually not
that
there it wasn't as hard as I thought it
would be like I was expecting it to be
that but it was definitely like there
were there are things that I thought
were like oh yeah I'll just like over
there and I could do that before lately
Jamie immediately got caught like I was
like oh I can I can get this key really
easily and not only was the perception
of the guard like way more keen but it
takes like there's that that there's
like that period we're like they have
this um little bar and it'll like oh
they're kind of like looking for you and
then it goes to the phone like alert
status you can make that bar a lot
shorter so immediately was like hey you
I'm gonna kill you now and I'm like oh
shoot okay well so I like I had no time
and I just run away and I died
damn and using that like faceoff ability
sounds pretty imperative yes definitely
like way more reliant on powers Oh
another one of the things you could turn
off wise when you pull up the little
like circular radio bar you can just set
it so it no longer slows yeah so I guess
I'm playing on PC I was like I had to
use the hotkey right like that's the
only way to do it now because that thing
is useless that's cool but that sucks
hold on where the [ __ ] is Domino yeah I
have a hard enough time wheeling through
that thing when I and when it does stop
time in prey I liked it was like a
spiral cuz you got so many powers like
spiral through it speaking of what was
it like going back to like the designer
universe after playing pray this year
pray was one of my is still probably one
of my top five games personally me too
and I love pray and but it was almost
refreshing to go back to rather than one
big connected open world it was
refreshing to go back to where you have
these discrete missions I allowed to
sign or to but of course in a dishonored
one and death the outsider it kind of
makes you it's still like the this
sandbox thinking but it's also like I
know I could go in and play for an hour
hour and a half beat a mission and feel
like I just really like really got
everything out of it like it
compartmentalizes so you can sit down
and say I'm gonna do this contra
this mission and feels like yeah just
and I think this game like more so than
the others just feels like it's designed
more for experimentation like I felt
like I had more freedom to just kinda
like mess around than I did any other
games yeah we went back and we did our
series on Arkane studios at a really
interesting conversation with Harvey
Smith he was saying based on like a lot
of market research and play testing
people despite what you would think
about like prices and complaining about
lengths of games PTIN many people today
prefer games to be shorter mm-hmm like
so like you were just saying it actually
kind of makes sense that something like
this would have what how many missions
now five five instead of 12 in Tucson or
two decided to felt a little too long to
me as much as I loved it I think the
length of this is perfect right yeah I
thought the same about lost legacy like
from that finished I was like wow that
was like it took me exactly six hours
and everything about that game like
pacing in length I was like that was
perfect that was a a good Saturday
afternoon playing that game had a great
time yes not to say that like arcane
won't keep making long longer form game
right is funny to like see how many like
comments and complaints are about on
paying $30 for hell-blade one of my why
would I do that but I was like I really
like those of course I play a lot of
games for work I'm not I used to be one
of those persons people who would you
know buy a few games a year and try to
play a lot of those which I missed that
but I'm also like it's it's still
awesome to play a lot of games but that
maybe that's why I like these more
double-a sized experiences more there's
there's a lot of games where like I
don't want to leave yet you know like
there's games where I'm like oh I don't
want it to be over because I'm enjoying
it so much but then the I think the I
feel like that less and less the older I
get tubes it's like I I like having
completed something and having felt like
I got the full story and I I got
everything I can get out of it and now I
can move on to the next really cool
thing so like the fact that echo that
you said you I can beat that in seven
hours is like that's perfect because I
want to experience this there's so many
other things I want to do yeah a lot of
it for me has to do with like the way
that games up games paced
I think some games can be like a 50 hour
experience but it's pace
weh-weh like it feels fine it has to be
pace probably right yeah but then like
the worst example I always think of was
a lien isolation for me I love that game
but there was like a point in that game
where I was like okay I'm kind of ready
for this game to be over and like I feel
like it's sort of wore out worn it's
welcome in terms of like mechanics and
the stories just feels like it's really
stretching itself and then it went on
for another like five hours and I just
remember those last five hours kind of
being a real sloth being like oh my god
I want to head and it felt like they
were like no we have to hit a certain
benchmark so that we can justify the $60
price and people don't get mad and I was
like oh man like I would have really
preferred to just be like this 7 8 hour
experience instead the phantom pain
dragged on way too long for me that's
like the key example I can think of
right now is like oh there's another
eight hours I'm going back through all
these side missions I haven't been doing
yeah I just sign our death the outsider
is how as of now good last Friday
I've gotten the chance of like two of
the missions I'm loving it so far I do
think I do think it kind of falters at
the end again mission wise I think that
first half is sort of the peak and the
other half is not as good but it's not
bad by any means it just it didn't it
didn't end as strongly as I wanted petco
pan job in the YouTube chat was saying
quoting me saying people want a shorter
game sorry but we don't have to pay full
price for a game I want a long
experience and maybe you don't but I
mean like I said this is from one of the
more talented creative directors who
does a lot of market research and but
again this is 30 bucks yeah it's perfect
right that's why it games like
hell-blade that are lower price for the
time length or kind of a cool hopefully
emerging market I also just I don't
really think of it as far as like time
and money really cuz it's like not I'm
not playing games just to spend time you
know like it depends on what you get
it's like yeah I'm not gonna pay more
for a two hour movie versus an hour 20
minute movie it's the same thing
differently but I guess the way I think
about it it's like okay well I could
have played like yes if I was to put my
like dollar like the 60 bucks I spent on
in isolation if it was only seven hours
supposed to that 15 like yes I
technically like my dollar to time ratio
was said the last five hours are slow
enjoy those last five hours then it's
like well in that since I wasted five
hours you want a game to respect I kind
of wasted my money like it you know I
don't know that's how I do it
I prefer quality over quantity almost
every day but yeah death the others out
you can go read alessandro here at
GameSpot to review up on site now you
did the video over yesterday's that up
yep cool so that's on YouTube being spot
you can go check those out all right
cool
divinity original sin - I almost said
divinity - again don't say that yep
another game
yeah it's divinity original sin - from
Larian Studios over in Belgium Belgium
the Belgian studio from Belgium also one
of the writers in the teams Kevin Ben
Ward formerly before Pete Brown was
review that are here at game spot for
how many years not 12 I don't know it
was a long time so he worked on it but
jean-luc you and I have been playing it
Rob you've been kind of watching over
our shoulders because of all the weird
[ __ ] we're doing in that game just
you're just wearing a boy I really like
that game yes so I played a little bit
of the first one I liked it a lot but I
never got into it because they're so
dense this one's even even more friends
but somehow it's not overwhelming me yet
because I've put maybe eight hours into
it and I'm still in the first area I
know Dave's you and over over in our UK
office spent like 16 hours yeah that was
a cool character that looked so sick
it's very cool but it makes the game a
little harder because you have to cover
up your face or most people who will run
from you so that's it was so funny he's
weren't like what you know Mike looking
over his shoulder like why are you
wearing a bucket and he was like so he's
in the menu inventory which is like full
HUD just like we've a Gleeson oh there's
a little bit less of it Apache so you
can kind of see this kid he was talking
to Mike goes like remove the bucket kid
immediately just starts running just
like imagine that in real life
Jean with your saying so you could play
co-op in this game which is amazing
because it's already it is dense as hell
Jeep has held the emergent situations
that come out of like that figuring out
how you can combine attacks and
elemental stuff but also just how you
can combine characters in your party
like sometimes you'll go up to this one
character that this this lizard
companion that you have has beef with
and then he'll go up and talk to him
bill yeah yeah go talk to him I'll catch
up
later in the hill his attitude towards
you will increase because if their
attitude decreases too much toward you
they'll just leave the party forever I
have not seen that but if that can
happen and the lizard hates me some I
guess please go talk to him I don't want
to lose you you're my best fighter but
also then a different character we'll go
up and talk to that same character I got
I got to talk to him too and all of a
sudden she'll just she'll be like and
it's like it's like text from the
narrator be like she promptly put a
needle in his stomach and ripped it made
him stare at his own got something there
it is probably good here's a great
example of this is me playing co-op with
Ben Gingka and my brother and this is
one of the party members you can get and
I basically like was talking to him and
saying like hey I really want to get you
ass party member we basically sealed the
deal all of a sudden the dialog box just
booted me out and Ben had like just
taken a shell you can pick up objects
and just throw them and he threw a shell
at the dude and then all of a sudden the
guys like you have dishonored me and
they're just like and basically were
just like so he won't join our party
anymore we have to murder him now should
we reload should we like start over and
we were thinking about words like you
know no we're gonna we're gonna stick
with this and we're just gonna kill this
guy
yeah this game is uh me like debating
like I have a save we can load just f5
at any time and he'll save it really
fast there's there's something to be
said about like just hearing that like
as funny as it sounds like when you
think of like a like a classic like
squad or buddy Trek adventure movie like
there's always that one shady character
he's always screwing up everything it's
it's a heist thing it's like yeah he's
weird he's a loose cannon you can
accidentally just piss off anyone and
murder anyone like completely 180 right
like yeah Oh Mike you had said another
really funny thing well sorry speaking
of Michael Madsen and mr. blonde being
that that like minutes so totally yeah
he's just gonna cut someone's ear off
what was I talking about
you were playing and you go ah whoops I
just accidentally killed her apparently
apparently you were like addressing
a woman who had like her throat well she
was bleeding out from this story point
that I won't spoil and and I was I was
pressing a cloth to her neck and trying
to save her and Chris who works here
walked over behind us and we were
talking about it and I was kind of
listening to your conversation like a
work-related one but also playing and
some I honestly think my finger just
spazzed out and I click through to
dialogue options instead of one and the
next one which was aligned with my mouse
and it just said slit her throat it's
one of those games where a hat like the
best part of this game is just rolling
with your choices kind of like echo it's
all coming back now but it's like I was
like I could low to save but I also kind
of liked the idea that my character
literally just accidentally killed her
right you might not be in character but
I'm also kind of like we'll figure out
who my character is as I go you could
argue that you mercy killed her she was
already pleated it said you decide to
finish her quick and give her like
solace or something I was like I
probably could have saved her if I
really put my mind to it otherwise known
as your a dick and you just killed her
no question so I didn't play the first
one and a little intimidated to jump in
can I just play it do I have to know
anything about no no no not at all
yeah you can just jump it yeah you can
just jump right in yeah you can play a
few reviews are saying this is like one
of the best like isometric very like a
traditional PC RPGs in a long time if
like um people always reference Baldur's
Gate to as one of those like gray ones
and we get a lot of those recently yeah
no was it a plain scape torment that was
way more you're right for sure I played
that and that hat was way more all
mostly based on like text and
the combat was few and far between this
game you can just fight with anybody at
any time
not that you need combat for a good game
like this but that kind of feeds into
your character and stuff well this game
the the combat is really rad cuz it like
plays into this like experimental like
kind of like elements combo stuff so you
get you know there's basic stuff like
okay I'm gonna lay down oil and then I'm
gonna shoot it with a fire arrow and
it's gonna spread fire everywhere but
then you get like weird stuff where it's
like okay I just killed that man in a
pool of blood it's now like spilled on
the ground and I can Electrify it now
there's electric blood that'll like zap
anyone also undead characters if you try
to use a regular healing potion it will
hurt you hurt them and a lot of food
does too and I still have not figured
out which food cuz sometimes food heals
me sometimes it's probably I was gonna
say ro no no I just picked up an apple
and I ain't no trust me and then I
picked up cheese in it I hope I pray you
have more stories of just like I'm
trying to like let me get this wheel of
cheese Russian Roulette pull the trigger
Mike or it's like you're like just like
some questions like come to my house
like young man like take off the bucket
no okay
just putting stuffing it is an honor in
this household that you keep this bread
it's either take off the bucket or eat
this dark meat man no but but also
poison heals on dead characters right
have to use poison so one of the
characters she is an elf I believe with
a scar on her cheeks you know yeah she
she has this ability she could just
throw these poisoned flasks so someone
or she maybe she had one equipped but
she came up next to me in a fight like
you see a bunch of characters grouped up
here and - I have two undead characters
cuz my main character is undead but you
also get another companion and we were
really low in health so I had her throw
the poison like bomb essentially at us
so it killed the person next to us but
gave us ran right yeah it was like I
need healing and she just like throws
like a dagger in your back oh yeah Oh
much better quick sign I'd be ideal
throw some cyanide my face
so this situation was actually kind of
cool so I picked um one of the origin
characters so you have um you can make
your own custom character but you can
also pick an origin character which has
like its own specific backstory that
actually can then like play into the
into the narrative and my character's
backstory
because I heard like that's if you want
like that's maybe a good way to start
it's just kind of like pick an origin
character because you get that extra
narrative my character has like a voice
inside their head that like possesses
them and tells them the do stuff like a
demon like a literal demon oh jeez okay
more and more literal and I like met
this woman who's like a like a seer and
she's like oh like you got this like
demon inside you and my curse is like
how did you know that she's like yeah
like it's really angry and like do you
like do you wanna know more about it
because I know some stuff cuz like I can
see the future and you're like please
tell me and then the demon like took
over my body and like I started
attacking her it's like now I'm in
combat and so I had to they're like okay
the only way to get either I have to
murder this woman or like I'm gonna play
this game right now my or I have to get
my character down to a certain amount of
health to like knock me out of the
trance so I had to have all my other
companions like attack me so I have like
all my conveniens like shooting me in
the face with bones it's is such a like
a Dungeons & Dragons ish kind of like
you really start developing a character
like through your abilities and stuff
but also through the choices you're
making that kind of tie into it's so
great at I'm already loving that aspect
of it but it's also very much like this
is another kind of funny thing that
happened that I don't think I told
everybody because it was embarrassing
that whole so there's your you're in a
prison like I think most the gameplay
we're seeing right now you're on this
island is it's called fort yeah it's
great name area but you you're
essentially trying to figure out how to
get out of there and then but there's
it's such it's so great at like giving
each character a motivation to get out
there he'll be like I need to go see
this person about regaining my throne
cuz I'm this exiled Prince and then this
girl will be like I need to go I need to
find this area apparently there's this
safe spot and then but also how you're
getting out a lot of the key to the
companions will kind of have or you'll
just stumble upon strategies like I
stumbled into this area by following by
playing hide-and-seek with this kid and
then I came upon
it's like 1,000 years yeah that was in
your old night with a spear through his
chest that had petrified him but he was
also an undead character so my dialogue
options when I pulled the spear out of
his chest
and he came back to life kind of undead
life he's like oh thank you you're one
of my kin and I appreciate it but then
that gave me a way out because he's like
here's a map you can go to this part of
you can sneak in by pressing this button
on this statue in the courtyard but then
there's another point where going back
to that guy a lot of many lizards are
seers as the only lizards are seers now
the elf elf is okay so they're seers
they can essentially they're kind of
like they're kind of like ran from Game
of Thrones or something you can see
stuff but someone so she killed him
because she had beef with him she just
slid open his stomach I was like oh
great I hope I don't need him and I went
over to talk to someone else and he's
like apparently there's a lizard seer
nearby that can help you get out of the
prison like [ __ ] is there anyone else
yeah
can you are you a seer by any chance
okay it's really fun Safari and I want
to play more co-op right yeah we should
start a game co-op is it kind of changes
the way it reminds me of like playing an
actual D&D campaign where yeah you know
you're like okay guys this is what we
need to do but everyone kind of has
their own like objective or what they
want to do so I can split up so um my
brother was playing a skeleton we
couldn't figure out that he needed to
like put like a bucket on his head or
whatever so every time you try to walk
into like the area everyone would
immediately like murder all of us so
we're like okay you need to go hang out
in the wood no we're gonna go do the
quest and then eventually he's like all
right I got a hood I'll wear that
all right cool we can come in now he's
the Charlie Kelly I'm Marty ii yeah why
you what's what are you wearing bushes
for here oh that that's the stealth you
can stealth so I was stealthy up to
these enemies and then my character gets
extra damage when I'm on a high place so
yeah I'm a ranger and a range and so I
got up to the high ledge and then been
moved to this barrel over to where they
were and then I shot it to start the
fighting and set that giant crocodile on
fire is it like
I mean this is probably a dumb question
but is it like did you find a
detrimental at all like flame co-op
well no no as far as some of these
characters like I can't stop think about
the one you're describing we're like you
literally weren't able to control your
character because the demon was
controlled me controlling like killing
you co-op you get into these weird
things we're just um you know yeah it's
like okay I'm gonna go do this quest and
you're like yeah I went and like stole a
bunch of [ __ ] and then you can do you
can't like mess with people where you
could be like hey man check out this
sick sword Iife I bought I want you to
have it you're like oh thanks and it's
like totally stolen and then like our
guard will come on to me like oh you
stole that I'm gonna put you in prison
now and then you're in prison but he's
fine
or you can um take a health potion or
you can a poison potion diet red and it
looks like a health potion you can give
it to your buddies I feel like hey man
here have a here have a potion or
conversely maybe dye some potion green
and give it to an on get agree like you
the game you could just spend hours just
like messing with your friends well I
feel like there's so many opportunities
like really roll a one on any encounter
just just like totally mess it up right
and screw up and then you have to roll
with it like the idea of like oh I just
wait til every my friends can lower my
health so the demon escapes me just like
or yeah it's like I'm I was talking with
that guy and having a very nice
conversation and then my friend just
goes have been throw a shell of this
face yeah I mean a spirit it's hard to
say like I would encourage everyone if
you if you're into like RPGs absolutely
play this game it's definitely have a PC
plays game and I know like the game
player seeing it is very very dense to
say the least
menu wise possibility wise emerging
gameplay wise but you should definitely
try to play I I can't remember last time
I played a game where I was less prone
to like reloading a save I'm like I'm
gonna roll with this choice I'm if this
is this will make it interesting somehow
she killed our only way out of prison so
maybe I'll just be here for another 20
hours and I'll still find [ __ ] to do
you'll probably have a little better
time if you play it single player in
terms of just like traditional video
game like you know you can read all the
dialogue and kind of have you know
options with quests like when you're
playing co-op everyone has conversations
separately and you can listen in but you
could also like completely miss a
conversation because your friend like
went off and talked to another person
and you don't know what that
conversation was so there's a reliance
unlike talking with them or when like he
talked to this person activate this
quest if I go talk to them they don't
know who I am so like it's like oh you
have to talk to this person now because
you have that built-in relationship look
at that character so that can get like I
like that I know it's cool but it can
get kind of hard to manage and like we
hit a point where like say yelling at
Ben Jay what should we do and we're all
like why of this quest and it's like why
I have these three quests and we just
like had no idea what to do and like
it's it's a game that is so dense that
you can get lost and it just becomes
even harder when you have a bunch of
people want to do stuff but so if you
have to kind of like let go the fact
that like maybe you're not gonna get
that much accomplished if you're playing
by yourself but the room on the reverse
end like the satisfaction of playing
with people and like that role-playing
experience is like really really cool
yeah I would definitely say you'll
understand the systems and and except
play better if you maybe play like 8 to
10 hours of single-player and that's
really nothing in this game although you
certainly learn stuff together like
that's how we were like oh guys I found
out that you know poison hurts me and
it's a healing hurts me like someone I
mean like many people played a lot of
breath of the while it reminds me
nothing at all like breath of the wild
but in the sense that there's a ton to
do but somehow they make it so it's not
overwhelming so you don't mind that
you're missing out on a lot of stuff
because you're still doing a bunch of
these cool things that other people
probably didn't see yeah yeah I think
the best way to design something like
that is to just make it like I just
follow what you think is interesting
yeah and then you're not missing out
totally story's yours and the writing is
fantastic I'm not just saying that
really really helps it's funny like as
hell at some parts especially seeing all
this stuff like kind of interact my
character is I'm a polymorph so I can
turn into like
you like specialize in two-handed
weapons right now but you can turn into
like a astral a spectral bowl with horns
and then ram people or turn your arm
into like an octopus tentacle that stuns
people it's really fun so far yeah it's
like so much stuff like that he'll elves
in this game can eat body parts to like
relive memories those crocodiles like we
found a corpse later buying like like
Arnold's character ate it and we just
wrong no I said crocodile and it's just
like the last moments of this guy who
got like eaten by a crocodile and like
him being like that and thing could go
out this way huh like ooh-ahh cow but
then you actually can get like cool you
can like learn like how to do something
like oh we killed that guy but I eat him
and oh I gained the information that he
had and we can solve it that way and
then later used me to guy with one arm
he's like hey if you see my arm anywhere
and you're like yeah I actually like a
bunch of like severed heads in my like I
have just like hey let's just have my
elf eat it see what we learned my ELF
eat it
hey come check out my heads yep I have I
have a few separate limbs my backpack
right now so uh co-op wise it's four
player co-op up to four up to four and
that's it it's anything like down the
road this game seems like it's like no
sir there's an arena mode for a PvP
stuff yet is that out yeah yes that is I
believe that's out and there's also that
Dungeons & Dragons mode that we did a
while before that's yeah I was kind of
looting too that thing was really neat
today so that's in the game that's crazy
essentially you can make your own custom
like campaign oh cool assisted deeming
so you have one you have everyone played
the party and then you have a fifth
person play the DM and you can create
the map ahead of time and they can also
at any point pause the game and then
like change things around they can type
in dialog like they can completely
control it and they actually have a
really good like tutorial area they play
which is one of like the D&D like
starter quests as like an example of
like here's how to do it oh that's
totally real rad they're essential like
you can create your own campaigns and
the game also has really good mod
support for just all sorts of things but
you can download
other people's like campaigns and play
them and then like DM it yourself yeah
me so it was surprisingly Familia says
someone who doesn't know D&D though that
well at all it was surprisingly engaging
and entertaining to watch it was Justin
John Luke and Michael hi I'm played and
Justin was this like what was his
character his background was like
role-playing oh hello good sir he went
up to this like uh it was like some
goblin in a cave all the 20 well the 20
and like and the the DM from Divini was
just like oh my god he's like I woke up
today praying for this [ __ ] basically it
was like oh you're so pretty and it was
mesmerized by Justin and like the Goblin
led him through the cave that's all
these enemies to the end where they met
like the Goblin King every whatever was
and the guy was like I don't know what
Justin says like that he knows you guys
and he's like I don't know this guy like
good looks one more time the dungeons
dragons has always had of one up over
video games and that there's like
unlimited amount of options you can do
right yeah yeah and the single plan this
game feels like they're trying to push
it to its absolute limits where it has
almost at like breath of the wild like
oh can I try that like oh wow that
actually does look like they thought of
so many things but it still is at the
end of the day a video game that is
limited that DM mode is like just
completely it gives you the tools to do
what yeah you have like this visual
element that you can play with it's
really really cool I've not seen many
limitations yet at all you might like
eight hours yeah just the second player
alone it's insane what they can offer
its on PC yes so the first one came on
Xbox one
I think maximum games ported it about a
year after there's no word on that yet
yeah there's a tweet about that
someone's asking about yeah we have a
question we'll bring up right now
Richard you mind bringing it up
apologize I'm butchering his butchering
the same Tareq Rahm Shani on Twitter was
saying any idea about the release date
of divinity original sin to on consoles
the first of any original sin Enhanced
Edition worked really great on ps4 I
don't know when it's coming out but when
they put out the enhanced edition they
in addition to adding a bunch of stuff
they put out like controller support
which was actually like and it changes
all the menus and it works really well
and it also had like split-screen so you
do like couch co-op which is really
really fun that stuff is with this game
with this game that sounds pretty
intensive as far as like what your HUD
would look like well simplify no you
could set it you can say like oh we can
it'll be one screen that we shared or it
would like split it or you could set it
so it like dynamically split you just
lose some HUD elements or some like yeah
yeah it was pretty well done and this
game has it built in by default I got to
have some footage of me just like with
the controller support like they have it
built into the PC version from get-go so
it's a possible port for sure I think
they're definitely gonna do it I don't
know when but I imagine it will not be
as long as the first game because they
already have that mechanic like like
yeah here here's the controller support
it's like they changes the menus but
it's very like intuitive and easy to do
yeah this game was in early access for I
think the majority of 2017 it wasn't the
full game it was a big chunk of it but
now it's out on pc $60 full price from
Larian studios over in belgium
congratulations to them they made a game
that hasn't hooked and i am looking
forward playing it more and yeah like i
want to play it right now it's ready to
go it's fantastic dance yeah won't be
skeleton oh it's it's fun cuz yeah
between the poison and the way people
react to you and like characters keep
saying like one of your my dialogue
options as undead because you do tags
right character tags so I picked like
I'm an outlaw I'm an undead like race
but I'm also my class combat classes the
poly more for a meta more poly more if I
think and like you'll have different
obviously dialogue happens this is
nothing new but it's funny my undead one
is almost always tell them that your
undead
found a better helmet so it's just like
what they decide to join my quest like
because you have to convince them some
characters easier than others should I
tell them that I'm just a skeleton the
real-world application of that just like
hearing it being like your wife and
their and they're like reviled they're
kind of like the there there's very like
much prejudice against undead characters
in this world I think so this is an item
you can get where you can um any corpse
you can like steal their face back where
it is change your race to which like
because the game actually does have like
race politics like people in certain
quests like will treat you differently
because they're like oh this guy only
talks to lizards let me go find a lizard
kill him and steal his face and then
I'll go talk to this person and they'll
be more friendly with me see that seems
like the only option yeah Kali your skin
is hanging off your bones so one of the
characters she was what's her name it's
the elf that we just saw with this
gardener cheek and she like in the
dialogue after you she apparently has
this needle like you ever see kiss of
the Dragon with a Jet Li and who else is
in that there's a few people but he the
kiss of the Dragon is this one spot on
the back of his neck where he'd put a
needle and you just paralyze and bleed
of her so she essentially as this needle
she puts in people to like stun them and
it's like she's pressing against it
[Music]
she's like she's like one more inch and
I could kill you in the most painful way
possible and then meanwhile and it's
like I convinced her to join my question
very like like untrust distrusting of me
and uh and then after that I was like by
the way I'm undead she's like yeah I
know I didn't feel skin at all when I
was pressing the needle idiots so much
dialogue yeah yeah that's like half the
brilliance this game I can't imagine how
many words of dialogue they had to write
for every
situation it seems like astronomical I
can't imagine other game that compares a
million words apparent like compared to
like if you compare Skyrim to this it
must be like it must dwarf Skyrim it's
insane of course it's more text-based
and scarves a lot of like repetitive
like yeah I have not let me guess
someone stole your sweet roll yeah
it's a divinity is I love that game cool
so that's a show play divinity play the
outsider play poke and DX tournament
play echo for sure I'm staff we'll
probably have more of on that game
coming out this week because that game
deserves more pressed that's a show we
have a giveaway as usual Shiva who run
their Twitter account will be now for
this right now
overwatch Razer DeathAdder elite mice we
are giving away five of these it's
designed as an eSports Gaming Mouse
I like that black mat yeah so it looks
so as use as usual follow GameSpot on
Twitter if you don't already and then i
retweet the giveaway tweet and go to our
site i think you should be able to find
it there as well we change it up from
time to time and we're gonna pick the
winner is this weekend we'll get back to
you once once that happens we're gonna
pick random winners so that's a fun show
yeah pizza it'll be back in next week
there's had pizza last week I mentioned
I might be out this week for a video
shoot that might actually happen next
week it's kind of a last-minute thing
but otherwise it should be you know
semi-normal cast but uh yeah yeah this
year's ramping up huh
what do you mean just now yeah more so
like October yeah so what's what's on
the horizon so yeah like 20 Friday's
pokken tournament DX shadow of Thunder
shadow war is October 10th evil within
is the 13th
sorry I missed it what's the next one
the next one I can think of is shadow of
wars on the 10th I believe and then evil
within 2 is the 13th and then later in
October it's Super Mario Odyssey
Assassin's Creed origins and I'm
Wolfenstein 2 and then November's Call
of Duty World War 2 Battlefront 2 but
those are only like the massive Triple A
games and there are still a lot I'm
forgetting right now
I think South Park's December or no
sorry South Park's in November now right
no [ __ ] is that October someone else
talk I'm pretty sure South Park got too
late from its October release date
Battlefront to open beta I believe is
like next weekend or fractured but whole
is October 17th Wow still yeah was
December last year yeah yeah yeah
danganronpa that's it all right yeah V 3
V 3 it's out now no it's it's the 23rd
right yeah I'm playing through it and
it's um that's what I'll be doing but
that's a game that you gotta have played
the first two so no probably people
aren't going to come around playing
three Cup heads next week tub head
someone someone upstairs here in our
cbsi building he's a designer seems that
you guys know Alex
he walked by we have a monitor in the
lobby showing that shows like us our
stuff and giant bomb and then it's next
to like the scene at TV but he saw cop
hat he's like damn what is this was like
it's like a hand-drawn video game it's
like he's like how the hell they do that
I was like I have no idea but it's
taking a long time to come out next week
oh cool yeah that games hard and then he
said how much we suck at it no yeah no I
get it yeah games um I'm sorry brother
apex penguin we're just asking if we can
give him any life advice general I never
give up on your dreams love is the best
thing in the universe
love is what life is about yeah bye echo
someone from ultra ultra is watching and
be like uh I like this guy we're gonna
send you a life-sized echo I don't want
that okay that'd be horrified oh yeah
Marvel vs. Capcom infinite unfortunately
none of us got the chance to play it but
that is out apparently it's really good
Joey's been playing it we have a lot of
coverage up to Moore's rule review so we
started actually scoring reviews in
progress so he gave you an eight as now
but I think his full final review should
be up later this week with video and
everything so keep an eye out for that
but in the meantime as always leave your
thoughts in the comments whether you're
on youtube or on GameSpot we always look
through those and appreciate your
feedback will have
a lot more videos from Marvel vs. Capcom
infinite we're gonna be doing some face
scanning stuff with NBA Live and 2k
which should be hilarious as always and
yeah we will be back next week same time
Wednesday 11 a.m. here in San Francisco
we'll see that
[Music]
you